if you're a norwegian
if you're a norwegian click away from
this video now thanks all right now that
we got all the norwegians out of the way
yo [ __ ] norway worst country stinkiest
country listen up i'm going to tell you
what we're going to do
before actually quick summary for those
who don't know sweden used to own norway
i don't you know they were weird it
wasn't it wasn't cool
we decided to let him go here you go oh
you want freedom whatever okay then
these [ __ ] can you believe these
these [ __ ] went and got super duper
mega rich they're like oh well there's
oil there's like there's like money
everywhere here look at these [ __ ]
stupid norway literally they made so
much money that everyone in norway is
technically a millionaire are you
kidding me it's as if you divorced
someone that was really toxic and ugly
and then they got super rich
makes no sense worst part of this is
that and i didn't even know this sweden
had an offer from norway to get in on
this oil business 45 years ago they said
hey all right you give us your precious
volvo a little bit percentage
and we give you part of our maybe huge
uh oil thing that we got going on here
sweden said no to 85 billion
congratulations sweden you know it's bad
enough that we let him go to
we let go of three trillion right then
we were offered 85 billion to reconcile
and we said no
god damn it i hate norway oil and gases
make the norwegians crazy rich yeah i
know the stinkers look at them this is
sweden we could have been here for
finland for finland pursuit this stupid
norway
and their high gpp
gdp whatever i'm so glad we kept volvo
cars by the way now that we sold it to
china
norway is now the richest in the world
congratulations
i could be a millionaire oh wait
okay i've had enough i've had enough of
norway always flaunting their riches
their oil money and as owner of alaska
that's right i own antarctica i mean
yeah antarctica i now have decided i own
sweden
yeah king of sweden now hello i decide i
decided that's democracy if everyone
agrees that's democracy right you agree
with me
that's right okay cool so now that i
rule sweden here's what we're gonna do
sweden have been in peace for 200 years
200 year peace and in school in sweden
we always celebrate this like oh it's so
wonderful how we're such a peaceful
nation it's all a front okay
we've been hiding in the shadows we're
ready to strike do you understand do you
understand what i'm going with this
sweden is low-key one of the greatest
superpowers you see where i'm going with
this well everyone else is busy
squabbling with their neighbors which we
haven't been doing we've been pretending
to be friends with norway do you know
how hard that's been
and how difficult that is to be trump
pretend to be friend with someone for
200 years you don't like them you sit
back this has been swedish who wrote
this [ __ ]
we got the epic force navy gripin yeah
one of the greatest military advances of
the world we got weird looking drone
helicopter things and we got navy
what do you think norway has you know
they are so rich they're sitting on all
this money you think they'd have like
decent defense to
take care of it right bro i'm telling
you they got nothing they are nothing
norwegian armed forces 23k that's all
they got bruh lit
they have cyber defense why
idiots
what are they gonna do 23k we walk right
in i'm telling you i'm telling you as
king of sweden we're taking norway now
so sweden and norway have had a lot of
wars in the past okay we had the battle
of valor this the doll in the year okay
this is all okay invasion of allah
sweden one easy clap we can do it again
battle of t stalin sweden one easy clap
we can do it again battle of lair oh nor
norway one why
they captured eight of them that's such
a dick move that's so typical norwegian
we don't do that bro stop capturing the
swedes we don't do that okay we do that
but we don't capture as many that's
super rude norway see every time norway
when they grab a bunch of swedish people
they're literally vampires that's so not
cool man oh we got [ __ ] destroyed in
battle of longness we will avoid
longinus okay bruh why is this why is
this named after me battle of shelburg
shuttle bird
the bridge ah
bruh we will this is our okay it all
makes sense now this is where we will
strike the bridge the shelbury bridge
we'll strike through here we'll beat the
battle of blindness once again and we'll
walk right into oslo
it's a perfect plane we'll send all the
joss griffin from stockholm
from the king's castle
boom boom boom bing bada boom we secure
the oil and you know america is probably
gonna start fiddling and probably you
know they're like the annoying step then
right oh we can make all the worse we
want but other people know you can't do
that so we're gonna have to do it quick
we're gonna have to strike fast so it's
a good thing no no regions are watching
this video i'm thinking tomorrow
probably we should do this i think it's
a pretty sound plane will be 3 trillion
richer all the money will go to back to
the swedes and anyone that's willing to
help of course no regions you i'm sorry
you get nothing i like this idea i think
this is a strong good idea and then you
might say
it's unethical and
it's not cool
yeah to that i say bunch of cry baby
bullsh
okay we're i'm taking norway it's mine
now of course
as a king of sweden i am more leader
general master i've read sun tzu 50
times front and back and the point of
war
and the best biggest point i've learned
is that you have to avoid confrontations
at all costs
even if norway only has 23 000 pity less
uh defenders you know even if they
probably wouldn't do anything it'd be
better to do what i'm proposing as king
of sweden norway if you're listening i
know you're there you dummies i know
you're not gonna click up the way the
video
it was all a plan
you fools
i'm proposing what we did 200 years ago
make the norway sweden union look this
could be us literally denmark i guess
denmark can join too i guess what is
this painting
poster promoting scandanism between
norway sweden denmark hell yeah listen
we could all grow mustaches and shake
hands think about it it'll be cool it'll
be like it'll be like old times think
about it norway denmark yeah you can
join finland but stay off back off
step step back finland you cannot join
us iceland maybe and uh if you oh if
you're willing to accept norway i will
give you another part of and
antarctica
alaska antarctica
antarctica will give you another piece
of antarctica norway that i know you
desperately won okay you get the last
piece of the antarctica we get to share
the three trillion i think that's fair
you have 12 hours to respond norway make
your choice or oslo is ours
you thought it was gay but true
relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game
use any item in your inventory and make
memes inside tuber simulator add some of
our patented stickers in there stickers
our emotions memes our emotions express
your emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time
circle baby download it make a meme
[Music]
we need subtitles on this